you took the photos down from your
mother's case
yeah well the case was solved this one
is it we got these two killed born
hazard but that still leaves ten
metahumans that were created when I came
out of the speedforce how hard can it be
to track down ten bus passengers episode
404 elongated journey and tonight we
introduce two new friends of team flash
crap the first is Ralph didney that's
I'm gonna square jawed Oliver Queen to
cut away her Oh baby you know I've only
got eyes for you Ralph is a private eye
I smell a mystery what you learn is that
he and Barry have this sort of checkered
past he used to be a car dirty cop yeah
it kicked off the force
what Ralph learns discovers in a
hilarious sequence is that he has the
ability to stretch and now he needs
Barry Allen and team flash sort of
helped put him back together
[Applause]
the other is Reacher played by the
amazing Danny Trejo pleased to meet you
sir
Reacher shows up sort of the worst time
possible for Cisco go for coffee get to
know him a little bit better I bet that
you'll be pleasantly surprised at how
much you have in common
I'm going to hunt you oh it turns out
that that he doesn't really like men
dating his daughter he did this with all
her boyfriends I hunted her last one yes
where is he now I don't know he got away
I don't know where you go when you die
everybody happy Halloween we got new
flash to break down I don't know where
you go when you die Danny Trejo vs team
flash tonight and I know it makes it
seem like elongated man is kind of an
antagonist but really he is a good
character in the comics so I think the
writers are trying to pull a fast one
HR style where he starts out as a bit of
a dirtbag on this version of Earth and
then he becomes a good character over
the course of the season but there's a
new flash ring giveaway stuff happening
I'll explain at the end of the video
make sure you subscribe to get
everything because the World Series is
happening tonight too just so you don't
miss any of the videos make sure you
click that Bell to enable alerts because
it's gonna get a little bit crazy in the
next couple of days but you're starting
with the beginning of the trailer
working our way to the end the biggest
thing probably you know elongated man is
a really big deal when you meet new
comic book characters Danny Trejo is
gonna be awesome
but how many of you have not thought
about this board where Barry was piecing
together information on his mother's
murder since season 1 this was like the
big thing they unfurled in the pilot
episode
[Music]
when people talk about why season 1 was
so good I think one of the reasons why
is because that storyline was so primal
who's more precious to you in your life
your mother what would happen if she
were murdered by someone and they blamed
it on your father so it's such a tragic
storyline that's really hard to top in
successive seasons like iris is precious
to him but probably not quite as
precious as his mother was for most of
his life so the fact that they're using
the board in episodes again to actively
solve their mystery is a big callback to
season 1 like they said earlier this
year they're gonna try and give season 4
a season 1 vibe he's also taken down all
the evidence for her case as if he's
sort of putting her in the past like he
said he's moved past it like when they
were talking to the therapist he was
talking about all the people that had
died like oh yeah my mother died my
father died too but I'm past it I've
dealt with it I love therapy Oh have you
been before just once when I was a kid
after my mom died Oh your mom well my
dad died too just fair enough so those
are all things that happened while he
was in the speedforce for an
indeterminate amount of time because I
think we can agree that a couple months
isn't long enough to deal with that but
when you're in the speedforce you're
beyond space time so he lived multiple
lifetimes while he was in there so I am
fine with the logic but you do have
characters like Jo who's been in real
time for the last six months and has
recognized how big this has been for
Barry his whole life so when he sees
that he's like holy you took down
your mother's murder board this is a big
deal moving into Ralph dib knee I'll be
interested to see if they include any
lines of dialogue that talked about what
they thought happened to him after the
particle accelerator exploded because
way back during season one they thought
that he had died like I think Harrison
wells just rattled those names off maybe
they were mistaken maybe it is a
full-blown retcon I guess we'll find out
but I think we can assume that he has
not been at the police station for the
last couple of years so whenever he got
kicked off the force because Barry says
that he's a dirty cop that probably
happens sometime before the events of
season 1 so as with anything when they
introduce a comic book character who's a
good character in the comics but he
seems like a total dirtbag like in the
way the Jay Garrick seemed like a total
dirtbag of it like oh my god what did
they do to Jay Garrick oh you know
surprise something else is going on so I
wouldn't be surprised if Ralph didney
has some other reason for why people
think that he's a dirty cop like maybe
what happened isn't exactly what Barry
thinks happened so he'll find out that
he's not that bad of a person but when
you think about HR coming from Earth 19
because he was such a dirtbag on that
planet and he wanted to do something
better with his life he actually wasn't
that bad and the only big law that he
broke on earth 19 was that he breached
to another earth there big law was that
you were not allowed to travel the
multiverse because of a big war that
they had in their past which maybe
they'll address in a future episode
because now we have Danny Trejo coming
on the show and obviously it's just
mostly for the comedy of being the mad
dad who doesn't want people dating his
daughter but breacher was a pretty big
character in the new 52 he was a bit
more of a straight-up bad guy but his
abilities are a much more powerful
version of what Sisko and gypsy can do
I'll be interested to see if they ever
try to double down on him in a future
episode like they're like okay we're
gonna turn him into a real villain on
the flash if they try to do some big
multiverse story and involve earth 19 in
a bigger way because I know everybody's
asking about the accelerated man when is
he coming back there are so many
different flashes to the multiverse we
haven't met yet well because they're not
doing a lot of speedsters the first half
of the season who knows about the second
half of the season
I'm just not expecting to see a whole
bunch of other people besides that big
reverse flash twist that's coming in a
while they even put Wally West on the
sidelines so they would have time to
deal with the new characters they were
introducing the producers did talk a
little bit about Wally West when he'd be
coming back I might do a video for that
later this week because it's not quite
as big a deal as people think that it is
they did confirmed that he would be back
by episode 7 and for those asking about
Jay Garrick jesse quick the other
speedsters I think that they'll be back
hopefully they'll let Jay Garrick
participate in the wedding maybe the
second half of the season if we don't
see him but I think they made the wise
call to not stuff every last speedster
into every episode possible the first
half of the season the way they did last
year especially because they had a big
speedster villain
revealed around Episode six so I'm
expecting a similar timeline this year
for those of you asking when the thinker
and barrier will actually start fighting
each other
remember the timelines for season two in
season three by the time you get around
to episode six that's when you have a
big big villain reveal like oh my god
this is the guy that we've been fighting
what's going on and then through the
next couple of episodes they deal with
that you have the big crossover episode
and you're the midseason finale where
they actually fight each other so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video announce the winner when I post my
flash video later tonight there's a
gravity falls Rick and Morty Easter Egg
video that I've been working on I'll try
to post that if I finish it before the
episode happens tonight but you can
click here to listen to Jeffrey Dean
Morgan talk about being flashpoint
Batman and you can click here for all my
flash season 4 videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you